today like usual i have 100 minecraft
players here if any of these players
here can solve the impossible maze i
will give them free yogurt for 10 years
yogurt why why would someone want that
much yogurt server drop the gates
and in this video we're doing things a
little bit different chandler and tommy
are competing and chris accidentally
slept in today so carl's filling his
shoes
oh my gosh i just blew up people so many
people just died and just you viewers
know this isn't the only part of the
maze it gets insane the further in the
video we go i think i'm doing good i
think i'm doing good why is there just a
giant board of people here they're just
like sheep they're just following each
other oh wait a ravager i haven't seen
that yet oh my gosh they're actually so
close i don't know if they know how
close they are they are so oh my god
oh i hear it oh i just ran past it oh my
gosh all right he is the first person to
solve it okay oh wait i'm nearly out of
this segment by the way chandler i've
done it i'm like a gun among men all
right oh i'm out i'm out let's go i'm
going to win i cannot lose imagine if we
win all that yoga what do we do with it
uh eat it wow they got out quick
oh don't wait for me
oh my god everyone's pushing me
are you really chris if you're not
killing people
oh
are you doing good no no
oh dude okay when you get so high up you
almost die of fall damage yeah you can
make that oh he can't
oh and he died he has some restart oh
oh why are they doing this to me wait
are they sabotaging
i you killed him
oh my god oh my goodness gracious
stop it man why are you doing this to me
i'm so low hp yeah
okay i made it i made it i'm waiting
oh wait i never told the contestants
they're competing for 10 years supply of
yogurt they're all going to exit
everybody i forgot to tell you what
you're competing for
whoever wins this challenge wins a free
supply of yogurt for 10 years do you
mean less place right hey i'll check the
yogurt
i don't think there's actually a path
for them oh wait because we broke blocks
let's take it away let's take it away
server open the second gate let's
continue on to the next trial oh wait
okay we can go oh is this ice this is
impossible wait if we fall do we respawn
back there at the very beginning oh i
failed i'll find out for you okay now i
died carl i think we should welcome
tommy to our videos with a little uh
nudge no
oh no
no are you kidding me dude we can't die
again then
i said oh no why why are they oh wait
he's teleported on to me let's see how
much we can make tommy rage in this
video this is bad this is he's just
stabbing me
what the hell
that's not fair tommy where are you dude
i'm right back at the spawn big j just
decided to stop me we mustn't have that
ah it killed me now before i drop this
third gate i gotta do something evil
lava pluto assemble hi how are you i
need you to make this ten times harder
how hard do you want it jimmy hard if
you want a 10-year supply of yogurt you
got to have a big brain we've got to win
this think of how cool we'd look i'll
give you half of it really no i love
yogurt oh my gosh
yeah that serves you right oh my god
what did you guys do i'm changing the
layout of the maze to trip everybody up
wait what the heck how are they all done
don't worry these next few levels are
unfathomably hard and the crazy part is
if you die at any point in the maze you
have to start from the beginning
whoa that kid's hacking
oh wait
wait wait wait we got a hacker in that
lobby tommy you caught a hacker yeah
yeah we found a guy just hacking do i
get rewarded yeah it was tommy that
found him since you tommy all on your
own found this hacker you get it thank
you thank you bruh i'm not seeing why
you can't oh
okay i used the bow they gave me i used
it smart
we used our ender pearl look i only want
the biggest of the brain to win the
yogurt what if we did this
i'm gonna lay oh what are they wait what
guys
carl's right there
are they looking are they looking they
use the pearls chandler cheated there's
no way chandler got here without a pearl
okay right here
oh it's thumb all the way back wait wait
if i die i go all the way back i'm just
gonna
reappear wait chandler tp'd no carl no
i made it i made it i think i gotta do
the unthinkable we do not tolerate
cheaters
dang get banned nerd
they bug you we're gonna open both these
gates at the same time three two
open the gate oh wait oh they're letting
me forward once you make it up this
mountain it's not even over there's
still more up here tommy's dwindling
this lead a little bit tommy you just
lost first place what are you doing can
i hit them yeah of course
oh you helped him oh you should have hit
him oh no this is what i get for hitting
people i just feel 1 to 10 how nervous
are you i'm pretty nervous i'm very very
do people in england eat yogurt yeah
yeah i think so if not i think i think
my mum might what if we just uh did this
oh what would you say i was so
concentrated i will eat the yogurt oh
i'm back can't even climb ladders right
look at them hitting each other off the
ladder wall
oh okay i'm at the top
carl
reckon i can hit him as well oh i can't
wait get him off get him off
giant nader yeah i wanted to ask you if
you won the 10-year supply of yogurt how
would that make you feel i kind of
discussed it i don't really i don't
really like yogurt
oh well then you should just jump off
the the mountain over here my mom likes
yogurt though my mom likes sugar why
does everyone's mom like yogurt but they
don't like yogurt i love yogurt
wait so can we not die now if we go on
an orange one you go back to the start
oh
why did you do that wait a minute carl
yes did we steal this from fall guys
no
see how they can tell where they've been
why would you do that well i'm in the
very front no you're messing with them
so hard chandler stop rejoining you
cheated bro i've been here the whole
time well just be clear chen chen i know
i lost tommy have you been hitting
people when other people can't hit you
i'll does that sound like something i
would do
why would you do that yes yes it does
carl let's drop all the gates when they
finish this they can just win oh my god
there's still so much to go wait so this
is the last one this one here you wish
that was the last one we actually have a
custom made mr beast gaming logo maze at
the end i wish someone else would take
one for the team i got you back up yeah
big c
jailer
oh my gosh imagine falling in the first
jump wait if i die now do i go back to
the very beginning oh no surely not
tommy if you die now you or anyone you
go to the very beginning of the maze oh
my god
oh there is a lot of pressure on me
right now
i'm in second place i'm in second place
oh my goodness there are so many people
still in the first part of the map carl
look at this look at this look at this
stand up this man is blocking the action
oh
why would my
place on that tommy you're gonna have to
hit the the mob oh no but he's on that
block you gotta go nikos are you gonna
sacrifice yourself tommy so nico's can
win 10 years a year
tommy yeah first place oh
there you go that's what you get for
being a jerk oh my god
here move nico's in the call i want to
get you in the same call as tommy the
guy who ruthlessly murdered you play the
clip
what do you want to say to this guy who
has millions of subscribers and doesn't
need a 10-year supply of yogurt yeah but
nico we could be friends before you you
were doing me
okay
maybe we don't have to include the clip
of a man swearing at me to make up for
tommy slaughtering him i'm going to tpm
here to this part of the map you can
continue okay thanks whoa tommy's
already on the red line again i'm going
i'm going fast i'm like the flash but
quicker i'm like usain bolt but me look
at all the ravagers and mobs in here
this part is insanely hard good luck
whoever tries to figure it out all right
we got one that entered all right quinn
is making grounds wait this guy no he's
in second look at this guy oh oh wait
this is one ahead of him jimmy oh i died
all right you're walking where someone
just died oh no watch out oh you're
pinned down
now people are getting crushed call me
tell me tell me i'll make a deal with
you yes i love deals and money if you
tell everyone watching right now to
subscribe to mr beast's game i'll tp you
up for it all right all right everyone
subscribe to mr beast gaming check the
subscribe button and oh you're watching
okay
okay i'm here i'm here
no way
he just died
everyone keeps dying to the mobs how
about this server despawn all the mobs
go go go all the mobs are gone whoever
solves this mrb's gaming logo first wins
the yogurt gamer you're currently tied
for first if you finish soon you get 10
years of yoga what's going through your
mind uh well i'm in the middle of class
so i'm kind of stressed about that as
well wait what
good man gamer good man at some point in
time you've already passed the right
path to get you to the end
i'm here
oh oh
oh oh oh congratulations camera squad
you just won 10 years of yogurt yeah you
can go back to class and uh i have not
pulled my teacher so yeah just just let
me know when you want yogurt okay all
right thank you for watching subscribe